[Music]
thank you very much for those of you who
don't know me I'm Shaun Hegarty I'm the
executive director of the Center for the
Study of existential risk which works on
global risks and long-term challenges
and I'm a program director with a center
for the future of intelligence which
works on the opportunities and
challenges of artificial intelligence a
couple of years ago myself and my
colleague Stephen cave wrote a paper in
which we outlined some concerns about
what we saw as an emerging narrative
framing artificial intelligence
development as a competitive race or
strategic global advantage this is most
famously identified with some quotes
that we've already encountered at this
conference from Vladimir Putin in 2017
and this point from the State Council of
China's new generation and artificial
intelligence development and framing
these these goals in some more
competitive language now as we've
already heard and Alan and Brian pointed
these things that nicely it's unclear
how much we should read into this but
where putin's quote came from a
discussion with schoolchildren and the
chinese phone well chinese leaders have
repeatedly emphasized how important and
how essential of global cooperation is
going to be around artificial
intelligence nonetheless one of our
concerns is that certain types of
narratives can easily sort of build up
and sometimes even reinforce themselves
so somebody writes about artificial
intelligence as a race other people pick
up on it and run for this people are
influenced by this some of them perhaps
decision-makers who then take actions
which makes sense if we're in more of a
kind of a race dynamic and that again
lends credence to the race framing and
the whole thing kind of spirals and
we've seen a lot more and public
articles and policy reports that frame
intelligence in these terms I've been
asked to give a framing talk for this
issue of races and artificial
intelligence I'm going to do that by
making a number of argument since the
jessyca n--'s
one is that competition isn't
necessarily bad a lot of competition is
good secondly contemporary artificial
intelligence i'm not sure it makes sense
to frame it as a race full stop and said
what i think is happening is a lot of
different types of competitions on
different levels and in different ways
at the same time thirdly there is not a
race so to speak towards artificial
general intelligence happening right now
the goal is too far often too poorly
defined for something that however
fourthly at some point in the future a
critical mass of people might see this
as an imminent thing and such a race may
emerge basically i think it would be why
there are some serious concerns about
artificial general intelligence being
developed as part of a competitive race
for security and other reasons
sixthly there may be opportunities
certain key points of which communities
like these can really influence the kind
of bringing them of how we develop
artificial general intelligence
particularly at key points where for
example a critical mass of people
researchers decision makers and which
one seeing this is a long-term
speculative issue to something more
imminent and we should be thinking about
what we can do to have a positive
influence there one way is by having
well develop proposals and
well-developed and plans in place that
have buy-in from a number of key actors
who might have been thinking further
ahead on these things and the other
thing we might think about is the
culture and the environment in which an
artificial intelligence is developing up
until that point both in the research
community and in the broader governance
policy and other stakeholder ecosystem
around that and by that I mean practices
principles and precedents types of
collaboration other things that do or
don't alliteration so right now
I don't think that it makes sense to
treat AI development as some sort of
global race what we instead have are a
lot of different types of competitions
there are research groups working as
hard as they can to achieve certain
fundamental and breakthroughs and
applications earlier there are companies
looking to apply artificial intelligence
the various industry and business
applications whether it's in medicine
healthcare finance manufacturing
what-have-you
we have companies and nations trying to
be in a good position to bring
artificial intelligence new emerging
markets we have national strategies
being developed by a whole range of em
nations where policymakers are really
looking to make sure that there are
nations and their societies are best
supported and by artificial intelligence
and not left behind and so that M the
economies do as well as possible in the
future with artificial intelligence this
is all quite natural and healthy
competition can drive innovation
progress and beneficial societal
applications now obviously there are
things that we need to bear in mind
though you know in the drive towards
automation we should think about making
sure that people whose jobs are replaced
don't get left behind we shouldn't
deploy AI systems cry maturely or
carelessly in situations that might
exacerbate biases in historical data we
don't want to make sure that privacy
isn't undermined as we push to gather
more data to make better applications
but competition isn't necessarily
inherently about things looking at a
more geopolitical level a lot has been
recently written about concerns about
for example power becoming concentrated
both in leading corporations developing
AI and in the nations in which those
corporations are based are embedded
scholars like - Lee and others have
written persuasively
about the concern that we might end up
with nations that have a huge advantage
that are effectively offering
services to developing nations in such a
way that would be very difficult for
those emerging nations to pull
themselves up and be equal partners at
the table companies might end up with a
very difficult to overcome advantage in
things like research talent in access to
computing facilities and access to data
and leading groups might be able to play
at those role in influencing national
and international governance and
regulation but and there's been a lot
written about concerns about a military
arms race and by this I don't just mean
lethal autonomous weapons and this also
takes into account application of AI to
decision support logistics information
gathering intelligence fibre security
supplies chains the whole gamut of
things that makes up offense/defense
security and given that artificial
intelligence is such an inherently dual
use technology in which fundamental
progress can be turned into applications
and applications can be repurposed for
other purposes so easily these issues
are going to remain quite intertwined
with an industry a military which is has
at its basis a competitive angle and a
security angle that might be somewhat
antithetical to the cooperation that we
might want now looking a little bit
further ahead to this idea of an AGI
race and our special general
intelligence right now there isn't a
race war exist and most policy documents
talk about artificial general
intelligence as a speculative future
prospect that is decades or perhaps
hundreds of years away it and outside of
places like this an awful lot of mao
researchers feel the same way about it
it's not clear how much it makes sense
even think about this as a race when the
end goal is so poorly defined and and
difficult to say anything meaningful
about however that may not always be the
way things are if we are some decades
away from artificial
intelligence at some point it's going to
go from speculative to seeming more
imminent and at that point we need to
consider a few scenarios one is that
this server drive towards artificial
general intelligence might result in a
different sort of dynamic than all of
these different sorts of competitions
that we've been seeing before this
general intelligence has in the
definition generality a system that
defined as Anthony did that would be
able to basically do everything that
human intelligence is able to do as well
as us are better would imprints we'll be
able to occupy a huge number of niches
perhaps all of them which might mean
that there isn't very much room for lots
of different winners if this technology
allows us to make faster progress on
scientific goals economic goals
financial goals military goals it might
give the group or nation that achieves
the technology first an opportunity to
shape the future of the world in a way
unlike any technology we've seen before
and if as has been hypothesized this
technology was able to help us with the
process of developing artificial
intelligence itself it may mean that the
group who have achieved this technology
can continue progressing faster than
those who don't have it now I don't
think we can say that any of these
hypotheses are correct or incorrect
right now we've heard a lot of good
arguments why it might not be the case
we might have diminishing returns as
yahshua point to that earlier there
might not be a single point of which
something is AGI and whatever was before
that wasn't it just may not be away a
sense if they think about these things
it may be that we have a world in which
some tasks are best amenable to AGI
systems but narrow AI has an advantage
in other things but it seems at least
plausible to consider a world in which
developing something that we can call a
GI gives whoever achieves this burst
this huge global advantage and to think
about what this might mean for the world
and I'd point out that at the point of
which this may become imminent seeming
to people beliefs will matter
so the
people who are pushing forward towards
this what they think a GIM will be
capable will affect their actions and
what they think that their competitors
believe about AGI and what their
competitors will do will also influence
their actions now I think there are
really serious reasons to be concerned
about artificial general intelligence
and the drive towards it emerging in the
context of a race narrative one key
concern is this idea of safety ideally
we want and this technology that is has
such transformative potential to be
developed in such a way that am we move
slowly and carefully and paid due
attention to safety issues and that the
scientists who are working on the
forefront of it are sufficiently
convinced that they've solved the safety
issues before it reaches certain levels
of deployment it may be much more
difficult to do that if AGI is being
developed in a competitive setting where
other groups are working towards the
same goals perhaps not taking the same
sort of AM safety precautions and so
there feels like an a lot of pressure to
and keep pushing ahead quickly similarly
it may be a lot more difficult to answer
a lot of the key questions about how you
would deploy this technology once it's
developed in a way that's fair and
beneficial for the entire world how to
involve the voices of all the global
stakeholders who would be influenced by
this technology in a fair and equitable
way if it's happening as part of this
competitive race it may be more
difficult to share expertise between
leading scientists working on safety
issues between companies are between
nations to establish the kinds of
cooperations and collaborations we need
this sort of competitive dynamic might
even spill over into tensions of
different sorts geopolitical tensions
and even conflict and above all it comes
down to this question of well what if
somebody wins the race how can we make
sure that if this race is won by a
particular group the benefit is one that
results in benefit to all of us and that
we all feel is fair and equitable
in an ideal world we might want to see
artificial intelligence developed over
the last couple days as some sort of
globally cooperative venture some sort
of perhaps global Stern for AI where we
have scientists from across groups and
across nations working in together and
the benefits of the project accrue to
humanity as a whole rather than to any
group RNA and nation where scientists
work on this and don't bring it past
their stages until key questions are
being answered about safety issues and
issues of m control and where global
stakeholders are convinced that the
benefits are going to be distributed
worldwide now it's not clear how
feasible or practical this is but it's a
good goal so something we might ask is
in the world we're in right now where we
don't know if artificial general
intelligence is 20 years away or 200
years away or 2,000 years away and we
have all these kind of competitive
dynamics playing out what kind of things
should we be doing now so one thing is
rhetoric rather than amplifying this
rhetoric of AI as a competitive global
race and putting forward other types of
narrative artificial intelligence as a
shared global goal for a global good a
shared global challenge another is
establishing the kinds of cooperations
and collaboration that we need there's
already a lot of collaboration happening
within the research community it's
essential that as competition heats up
in different aspects of artificial
intelligence we maintain that spirit of
cooperation and particularly on issues
like research relevant to safety as we
develop more powerful capabilities
within artificial intelligence there may
be roles for different types of openness
of research publication and models and
different types of sharing models which
is something that we in a number of
other groups explored in the malicious
use of artificial
and report that was released last year
double engagement this conference is an
aspiring example of research leaders and
thought leaders coming together from
leading hubs in Europe the United States
China Japan and this is exactly the kind
of thing that I feel that we need to be
doing now it takes time to figure out
how to work together you know
particularly across cultures to
understand what our shared values are to
understand what we disagree on and why
and to figure out how to work together
if the stakes around artificial
intelligence are only going to become
higher now is the time to start working
together in this way and similarly
organizations like the partnership on AI
and play a powerful role in encouraging
globally engaged in global even
countable governance of artificial
intelligence
lastly precedence Yun and others pointed
out scientific communities can play a
powerful role in influencing how a
technology develops and the steps that
our community takes to put in place
certain principles and certain
precedents and may influence the way
that the technology develops in a
substantial way I particularly like this
principle from opening eyes charter that
they released last year or they say if a
value aligned safety-conscious project
comes close to building AGI before we do
we commit the stop competing with and I
said start assisting this project if
more groups were to adopt similar
principles and similar practices of
collaboration then I think we'd be in a
very good position when it comes to the
emergence of this drive towards
artificial general intelligence ahead of
this drive emerging I think there are a
number of topics that we can meet and
thinking on working on and questions
that we can be asking ourselves one is
what might be plausible and feasible
models for a joint
and general intelligence development and
project how could we incentivize
research leaders and experts who
currently reside within national efforts
or companies to take part in this as
well how would we make sure that this
project would be able to really achieve
alongside those what might be ways in
which this wouldn't work simulating
models for a global artificial general
intelligence benefits agreement who are
the stakeholders who need to be
represented what are the key issues how
can we make sure that benefits accrue to
everyone how can we make sure that if
leading stakeholders commit to this they
can be held and binding towards it one
question is what will be good enough as
I think mal I want to feel there's a
point there it's great to think about
ideal worlds but we also need to
consider the worlds that we're most
likely to end up in and the ideal
scenario might not be the option on the
table so we need to think about what
might not be ideal but what might be a
good enough solution that at least rules
out the worst-case scenarios I might be
concerned about lastly there's this
question about how we even talk about
and write about this issue there's an
irony to me it's talking about you know
races being bad while being up here
talking about races and there's it
points to a fundamental tension in that
we as researchers have a responsibility
to consider all the plausible scenarios
in order to be honest in order to
develop good ideas in order to engage
key stakeholders on those ideas and in
order to open up our ideas to the right
sorts of scrutiny but at the same time
it seems essential that by our actions
we don't serve emphasized or exacerbated
be exactly the site and types of
dynamics we might be most concerned
about all of these seem like really
useful things for us to be thinking that
ahead of time and to have done some
really solid thinking of about so that
we're in a position to influence the
global community when this comes into
view or a kind of a critical mass of
global stakeholders this is a very
powerful community and I'm now finished
it's research leaders as I said from you
know across the globe
people who represent the research
leadership and a number of companies a
number of academic groups and some of
the key thought leaders all of you
people thinking deeply and carefully
about these issues not just for the
future of your own group the future your
company the future of your nation but
for the future of humanity itself and
that's an inspiring thing it's I mean
it's been really a privilege discussing
all these issues with all of you over
the last couple of days to me it seems
like exactly the kind of leadership that
we need in order to make the best
possible progress and being the best
possible position when we get to this
drive towards artificial general
intelligence so thank you all for taking
the time to do this and to the
organizers for organizing this and I'm
really excited to know what will come of
it
I'm personally feeling more optimistic
than I have in years intelligence with a
GI but rather slow progress where a lot
of different actors are improving on
different aspects of intelligence and
might be less easy to convinced of your
a nice project of you know having this
AI Stern kind of thing because I think
we still want to have this coordinated
development even if we're not afraid of
her essential risk this because this
very high constitution of power could be
highly disruptive for society in many
ways can you think of other arguments to
convince a players especially a military
in different countries would be part of
something this is a very good question
it may very well be that we don't have
this single point that's very obvious to
point to that says now you know the
alarm bells going off or we need to work
together and it may be that what we have
is more of a kind of a frog boiling
water scenario where we've got this kind
of gradual development it may be harder
to make the claim in that case but I
feel like there's so an awful lot of
technology develops in this way where
it's
gradual and you can have the technology
developing gradually where it's still
the case the certain threshold or
thresholds are passed in the impact this
technology has in the real world where
something goes from not really measuring
that much or seeming fairly sort of
manageable to suddenly being very clear
that it requires a new type of
governance and I think you know we've
seen smaller versions of this in terms
of you know social media manipulating
elections and a range of other things I
mean maybe we would at some point have a
major cyber attack that makes us take
you know issues around cyber offense and
defense a lot more seriously even though
there hasn't been some sort of you know
qualitative shift or rather a continuous
development so it may be that we need to
think about in that case is well even if
what we're seeing is something more and
continuous we can see that the effect of
this technology on the world that we
live in means that there's something
that's very different now and that will
be very different in the coming years
then what the governance structures and
the collaboration structures that we've
set up for this are set up to account
for so I think there are ways to
approach this where even if the
development is more incremental we can
recognize that something that wasn't a
problem in the past is going to be a
problem now and needs a different
approach
[Applause]
[Music]